nuevo golpe en c nagpur parte del gobierno
decente y en el ultimo de los hades arriba
presidencial estados unidos hai
estableció oficialmente que China es
cometiendo un genocidio contra latina
Musulmana uigur es la región decina ni
en el oeste y el país asiático
su salto hacia arriba no se enfrenta a pare al
pueblo chino y para las naciones
sede civilizada togo y el mundo desde
partido de la republica popular de china
China comunista debe hacer qantas es
el rasgo que rindió venlo suigo rindió en
el cine se equipa ampliamente entorno
condena después de la comunidad internacional
pero si llega a la denuncia pero dura
estatura de la sede del gobierno con entre el
Diez políticas para comprometer la acción y permanecer.
clara en tu opinion sin venara medidas
Choques instantáneos de China para obtener un
fuerte impacto simbólico a nivel
potencias internacionales actuaron rai estado
inmediatamente 6 impone pero sanciona enfrentamientos
naba con la nueva administración biden
y con disculpa si vuelas si
curaron este mosaico durante algún tiempo
traer tecnología fue ascheri mind
primero la lisa dispara para revolver
represión bucle descuidado creo
a ver si les importa si no importan
producido si chocamos dioses forzados
swathe jabalíes y las áreas inclinadas del gobierno
cesa aprendiste de acqui estacion que tu no
dos violaciones y la venta en mano
ambos en china afirman que la langosta rey
educación construida si en su nariz
centro de formacion profesional
sal destinada carlos muslims on
figuras del terrorismo y el separatismo